في كوريا الشمالية
أصبح الحكم بالإعدام كشرب العصير،
ما هذا الجنون؟
في بلاد الزعيم الكوري كيم جونغ أون
لا تدري من الجنون ومن العاقل؟
إذا شاهدت التلفاز ستعدم!
وإذا تصفحت الإنترنت ستعدم!
وإذا تأخرت عن عملك ولو لدقيقة واحدة
فستعدم أيضا!! وماذا أيضا؟
فالأشياء والحقوق البسيطة في العالم
هي ليست كذلك في كوريا الشمالية!
الدولة التي يعدم زعيمها حتى أقرباءه
لمجرد خطأ واحد،  فما لجديد فيها؟
أو بالأحرى من الذي حكم عليه بالإعدام اليوم
ولم يرتكب جريمة؟
تنفيذ الحكم بالإعدام بسبب مشاهدة مسلسل تلفزيوني،
وأحكام أخرى بالمؤبد والأشغال الشاقة،
فما الذي حدث في كوريا الشمالية؟....
مسلسل Squid Game أو لعبة الحبار الذي لاقى رواجا عالميا
غير مسبوق على منصة Netflix،
يبدو أنه حقق نجاحا أيضا في كوريا الشمالية،
ويكفي أن يشاهده أشخاص محدودون في بيونغ يانغ
لنقول إنه يحقق مشاهدات عالية بسبب الإجراءات المشددة هناك،
أحد الأشخاص في كوريا يمتلك نسخة من مسلسل لعبة الحبار
أحضرها من الصين،  ويبيعها على محركات أقراص (USB)،
لكن لسوء حظ هذا الشخص تم ضبطه متلبسا،،،
فما هي عقوبته؟
تقول المصادر إنه تم الحكم على هذا الشخص بالإعدام
رميا بالرصاص، فهل انتهت القصة هنا؟ لا ليس بعد!!!!
فقد تم الحكم على أحد طلاب المدرسة الثانوية
بالسجن مدى الحياة،
لشرائه قرصاً صلباً يحتوي على حلقات المسلسل كاملة.
وفي مدارس أخرى متفرقة، تم الحكم على 6 طلاب
ضُبطوا أثناء مشاهدة لعبة الحبار،
بالسجن لمدة 5 سنوات مع الأشغال الشاقة،
كما عوقب المشرفون عليهم، بالفصل من عملهم،
بينهم معلمون ومدراء مدارس.
لم يكن الفصل من العمل هو العقاب الوحيد الذي واجهه مشرفو المدارس
التي غفلت عن الطلاب المشاهدين لمسلسل لعبة الحبار،
بل تم الإمعان في عقابهم ونفيهم للعمل في مناجم ومناطق نائية...
حكومة كوريا الشمالية تأخذ الأمر على محمل الجد،
وتقول إن الطلاب بدأوا بإهمال تعليمهم،،،
القانون في كوريا الشمالية دائما ضد وسائل الإعلام الأجنبية
بكل أنواعها وأطيافها،،،
وقد تم إصدار قانون مؤخرا، لإبعاد الناس عن وسائل الإعلام الأجنبية،
وتصل عقوبات المخالفين إلى الإعدام،
وبذلك كانت هذه المرة الأولى التي تفرض عقوبة الإعدام،
على مشاهدة أو حفظ أو توزيع وسائل الإعلام من البلدان الرأسمالية،
وخاصة من كوريا الجنوبية والولايات المتحدة.
وكان هؤلاء السبعة هم الضحية،،،
وبينما يحاول الأهالي إنقاذ أبنائهم من الإعدام والسجن،
فالسكان في كوريا الشمالية يعيشون مع الكثير من القلق والتوتر،
بسبب مواصلة السلطات في استجواب هؤلاء السبعة،
لمعرفة التفاصيل المملة للعملية،
مثلاً كيف وصل المسلسل إليهم ومن شاهده معهم
وحتى من كان له علم بأن لديهم نسخا من هذا المسلسل،،
وهل كانت العقوبات جاهزة ومعلومة لدى حكومة كيم جونغ،،،،
إذاً عن أي ظلم نتحدث؟ ...
السكان في كوريا الشمالية يشتكون ويقولون بأن العالم غير عادل،،،
فمتى تتحقق حرية شعب كيم جونغ؟ وإلى متى ستستمر سلطته
بهذه الإجراءات الظالمة والقاسية؟؟...
..
مسلسل Squid Game هو أكثر عروض Netflix مشاهدة حتى الآن،
ويحتل المرتبة الأولى في 94 دولة، ويشاهد في 142 مليون منزل
في جميع أنحاء العالم- وهي الأرقام التي تم الكشف عنها
بعد شهر واحد من عرضه، والمسلسل يمزج بين الرمزية الاجتماعية والعنف،
من خلال رؤية بائسة للمجتمع.
..
لكن يبدو أن مشاهدة هذا المسلسل في بيونغ يانغ كمشاهدة ملك الموت،
فالأشخاص الذين شاهدوا هذا المسلسل سيعدمون بدون رحمة!!
وأنتم متابعينا ما رأيكم، لأي سبب جديد سيعدم الناس في كوريا الشمالية؟
وهل يبدو ذلك غريبا؟..